hello and welcome to this video playing
a beautiful mind or not I cannot lund or
not Roland lecture ok so good fifty
percent score against him I know I think
he always plays plays well and I have
problems and he always has this bad
rating not always but she's at the time
ok here i think this night be five stuff
is kind of interesting
let's see I mean three takes 9 p-5 I
think it's interesting for wide I'm not
sure about is sexy in this position or
can I be five and now i think it is
clean d 5 i'm not mistaken Thank You
white is supposed to have a slight
advantage okay yeah night on b5 is a
very very annoying piece oh and okay it
doesn't seem to agree with that I don't
question how we know how it gets rid of
it now now the problem is that night
always a text to a seven-point how are
you ever going to move the rook from
eight this is the question
push mt8 Bishop to b6 maybe
ok so see untangling somehow yeah with
this ok I have a five though I maybe you
can go nite be 8926 now
I think if you could have done that
a a six is an issue my night doesn't
have good squares and not happy about
before you I liking away six I think
even though it's got a five which could
be no didn't we 5 mm I don't really I
guess many Musa
so very strange position so anybody able
to do something i don't know maybe black
here night to g6 you might be able to
regroup this yeah
I think it's still okay for white even
though it's not really really great of
course
oh shoot should I did not hmm and yeah I
they cannot move it and allow rook takes
III this is not possible I what a shame
what a shame
yeah i should have at least how to draw
here I mean at least not more than that
but losing is kind of awful
isn't there a way to give that away and
continue the game
you
you
time morning no there's no puss alert
here
anyway I Bishop takes Bishop takes just
wings I don't know what his issue is
here Bishop takes you three I mean it
just is winning
absolutely no chance whatsoever just
losing check maybe had some better try I
know it problem is he can probably put
me in some kind of sucks phone because
Jack I cannot I cannot enter his
position at all threatening would be six
foot this is check easily easily
prevented
now I totally hate to lose this game
after a fight are having such a
comfortable position out of the opening
where black is just suffering but i
played this just to yeah I don't know
without any great idea i guess and there
for example i could have just taken the
pawn this would have been a nice idea
just take a ball yeah you like it's just
suffering in a slightly worse position
and i managed to lose this kind of
easily even yet i shouldn't lose i have
it but he didn't he played this is
pretty nicely I should have never played
b5 I guess if I just stay here and do
nothing this is just this is just a bad
idea I just thought I didn't pay any
attention or something I can just stay
here forever for draw but here yeah yeah
this is good yeah it's quite quite
typical that the computer doesn't
understand the position it wants to take
and this is just a draw because it's a
complete fortress I think it is a
complete fortress but human players just
stronger and wins easily by taking one
c3 you know this is still given by the
by the comp yeah he's just invading here
yeah eleanor was an awful game really
really don't like to use like that from
a very comfortable position but i didn't
i didn't have any great idea played
without any idea and then play this
terrible be fine I mean this is not fun
but at least it's a draw if I do nothing
okay thanks for watching